y à l'entraînement avec le sac de frappe
l'exercice de la corde à sauter les
enchaînements en binôme esquive
placement de poing et de pied si
j'avance qu'est ce que tu fais wallah
pour être apte à distance on me toucher
et que je pouvais pas te toucher la boxe
éducative c'est les mêmes règles que la
boxe anglaise
à une exception on a l'interdiction de
frapper on a juste le droit de toucher
son adversaire pour ne pas nuire à son
intégrité physique en fait la section
boxe a eu de l'engouement au collège
saint louis
plus du tiers des élèves ont préféré
cette option plutôt que le latin ou
l'anglais renforcer la discipline
sportive et sa rigueur pourrait bien
déteindre sur l'écologie la boxe à
canaliser l'énergie
ça c'est très important et ça reprend
sont tous le respect des règles au
respect d'une gêne de grille des règles
de conduite et en espérant que nos
élèves porteurs reproduisent reproduit
célèbre ses règles dans l'établissement
rappelle c'est pas souvent la meilleure
solution
puis on apprend la discipline pas les
valeurs
on peut apprendre dans tous quoi
ces cours n'aurait jamais vu le jour
sans le partenariat avec le club de boxe
de montargis avec la mise à disposition
de la salle d'un entraîneur et des
équipements en contrepartie le club peut
espérer deux futurs licenciés en boxe
amateur
là c'est le début de l'année donc on ne
sait pas encore quand on va mettre les
gants et c'est ce que ça va donner mais
il ya déjà des personnes qui sont
prédisposées à des bons boxeurs de bons
boxeurs qui pourrait participer au
championnat académique de l'union
nationale du sport scolaire
le club de montargis espère accueillir
cet événement l'année prochaine